[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the multiverse
version of elon musk
without the money of fame and this video
we're breaking down some big one
division theories
the series seemingly now has a huge
callback to doctor strange
that i think actually sets up a lot of
things in the mcu
we also have a new theory about
hayward's plans and some cool little
details from the yo gabba gabba show
we're gonna be breaking it all down but
if this is your first time here then
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for videos on one division
that are almost as good as the show also
my grandma says anyway with that other
way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into the breakdown
okay so episode 7 ended with a big
reveal that it was
agatha all along this head bopping final
scene
also brought a lot with it and it seems
like we may have got our first look at
the dark hold in the mcu
disclaimer depends on whether agents of
shield is cannon or not we do not know
as our lord kevin feige hasn't said
hell snyder however throughout the
comics many mystics have used this book
to cast powerful spells
and it's definitely in the realms of
possibility that they're one and the
same
but how did agatha get our hands on it
exactly
well if we go back to doctor strange
there's a scene in it where wong takes
the titular character through the
library at kamatash
at one point where shown the ancient
one's private collection and can also
see
that one is missing now there's a lot of
things to be taken from this
and putting on our nerd hats there's so
many cool little details here that
reappear in one division
the first is that the books are
surrounded by hexagonal shapes
in order to hold them in place hexagons
have appeared throughout the mcu
but they're extremely important in one
division for a number of reasons
firstly the hex is as well the shape of
a hexagon
and secondly they appear across a number
of things to tie back to the magic
that's being used
thus we can take that hexagons might
actually be integral to the universe
and how things are built up shout outs
to screen crush for pointing out that
the cree pretty much have them in all
aspects of their society
and they also appear in guardians of the
galaxy as warp points
showing that it is possible to go from
one place to another
by traveling through them because
they're so intrinsic to how the physical
and mystical world are built
it makes sense that these books of grey
power are surrounded by them
when strange goes to pick one up we can
also see that there's an ominous orange
glow beneath it
and this color clearly exemplifies the
magic of wizards
throughout the movie it appears whenever
they cast a spell and it's likely that
the majority of magic
is tied to this color now wonders power
always
appears red and this is because she
draws from chaos magic
thus if we can assume that certain
colours are associated with certain
forms of magic
and different types of magic must come
with a certain colour
captain obviously now i'm bringing this
up is is because
in the show we can see that whenever
agatha casts a spell
that the color purple accompanies it and
the movie doctor strange
may 2 let us know where she draws her
abilities from
at the end of the film doc goes head to
head with dormammu
and we can see that his eyes are glowing
with you guessed it
purple the being then attacks the dock
several times throughout the time loop
and every single death that he deals out
comes with a purple tinge to it
every time cacillius draws from the dark
dimension we can also see that he has a
purple glow around his eyes
and therefore can assume a lot from this
thus
we can gather that agatha herself draws
from the dimension too
and this is how she's powerful enough to
possess wonder if you know the character
from the comic books you'll also be
aware that she's over 11 000 years old
and she looks pretty good for an ancient
one
similar to the ancient one now agatha
has clearly also prolonged her life
through drawing from the dimension as
well
and it is possible that she and the
ancient one at one point were opposites
to one another
now as of recording this i don't know if
agatha's age
is revealed in the show but i do hope
that we get to see the older version of
her
so we can put a pin in her tying
directly with the magic that we see used
in doctor strange
it's also possible that the darkhold was
indeed part of the ancient one's
collection
and that she stole this in order to go
off and craft her own spells
if it is true then we do know that when
it comes to why the book was missing
that it was agatha all along and it
and it's definitely something that makes
me think kevin foggy is a genius
when it comes to laying the groundwork
for easter eggs i really hope that doc
turns up to get the missing buck back at
the end of the show
but i guess we're just gonna have to see
now on to our next theory
and that involves project cataracts up
top before we get into the theory
i just want to say that i don't think
wander ever took vision's body from the
sword headquarters
yes i know what you're gonna say i'm an
idiot yeah but but hear me out
and let's talk about how hayward first
came into the show
introduced as the acting director of
sword he sent moniker out on a mission
to help the fbi
with a missing person's case that
eventually led to her coming across the
hex
at no point was his plan to track down
wander in order to get vision back
and it's purely by accident that the two
stories intertwined
when he showed up to the sword facility
he seemed surprised that vision was in
the hex with her
and it wasn't until the following
episode that he brought up wonders
attack on sword
as we've gone deeper into the show we've
learned a lot more about cataracts
but at no point has there been any
mention of the project being shut down
to the vision's body being taken
in fact it's far from that and it seems
like hayward is just monitoring the
character
whilst that still proceeds in the
background the more i've watched over
the footage
the more i've obsessed over this idea
and realized that what we've been told
is likely a lie we never see wonder exit
the facility with him
and the only thing that we have to go on
is the word of a guy
that i wouldn't trust with this
spider-man 3 title
no not you tom holland anyway what i
think happened is that wonder showed up
to sword after learning that due to
vision not being a person
that his final will and testament had
been ignored
wanda journeyed into the lab to take him
and started to wreck
shop but after seeing how they'd
massacred her boy
she left and went off sinking into a
deep depression
this allowed agatha to sink her claws
into her and heywood continued trying to
resurrect vision
in order to provide the planet with a
defense system to stop something like
the snap from happening again
monica returned to work and he sent her
off on this mission which is when she
got sucked into the hex
and he showed up to find that wonder and
vision were in it now up until this
point
i don't believe that hayward had been
able to resurrect his version of vision
and the reason why he was tracking the
one inside the fake reality
is to learn how the machine came back to
life however he may have
actually cracked the code on what to do
and it is possible that the big secret
that he's talking about in episode 7
is actually the real vision this would
lead to a vision versus vision standoff
in which the fake one would have to take
out the real one which has been
repurposed for hayward's
ultron terrier motives now this is a fan
theory of course
but i do think it explains why vision is
unable to remember anything before the
hex
including the avengers it is possible
that wanda met with agnes
or rather agatha who helped her to
create this reality
along with a new version of vision this
may be the one we see in the trailer
saying to her wonder and this actually
looks like the first time she entered
the reality
due to her clothing i think it will be
revealed that this is the start of the
hex
and the thing that keeps her in it is
the man or machine
that she thinks she's lost and finally i
just want to give a big shout out to
talia shuloff
who discovered that the yo gabba gabba
video we saw in episode 7
actually had a hidden meaning in the
scene we can see the characters dancing
along
but there's actually one missing and
that is the robot one
this could be a call back to how vision
a robot
is missing from the family might be a
reach though we then zoom in on the red
and blue ones
and these two colors represent wonder
and moniker and it could be playing on
the fact
that agatha views them as a threat
there's also the possibility that all
the characters represent someone in the
show
as well as the infinity stones which
their colours line up with
maybe an amazing detail maybe a reach
but you've saw about 80
of the video now so thanks for the watch
time anyway i'd of course
love to hear your thoughts on these
details and whether you agree with them
or not
also if you noticed a cool little easter
egg or a hidden meaning behind something
in the show
then comment below and let me know as a
thank you for interacting with the video
you'll be entered into a prize draw on
the 28th of february
in which we're giving away three copies
of the marvel phase 3 4k box set to our
subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the theories
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter heavy
spoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the commercials for one division which
will be linked on screen right now
we've gone through them with a fine
toothed comb and pointed out all the
hidden details
and how they tie into the bigger picture
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more
by the way thank you for sitting through
the video i've been paul i'll see you
next time
take care peace